- Speaking of music,
I found out that you're like
a huge Garth Brooks fan.
- I am for real,
and that actually ties into
our movie a little bit.
- [Kelly] I know, so that's where
you're doing the dance, isn't it?
It's like different lyrics.
- It is an homage to the dance, yes.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
- That I sing.
- I recognize the song, the melody, yeah.
- Yes yes yes, which you sang
your version of the dance.
- Brilliantly as it can be.
- Oh at the Kennedy Center!
But thank you!
- Oh my gosh.
You made Garth Brooks cry.
- [Kelly] Aw, thank you!
- And everybody watching it was truly.
- I watched that like 30 times.
- [Luke] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Thank you!
- Literally during the filming we
we were talking a lot about Garth Brooks
and Billy actually wrote that song
during the filming of it.
It was not something
that was totally planned.
- Oh, really?
- [Billy] Yeah.
- It came out of a
conversation that we had about
what music we liked.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because we didn't know each other
before we started shooting.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we were trying to
get to know each other.
So I said to him, you know,
what kind of music do you like?
And he said, "Actually,
I love country music.
and my favorite singer is Garth Brooks."
And I was thinking my character
in the movie at the end
I don't want to give it all away,
but you know he needs
to make a grand gesture.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, 'cause he's
in love with this guy
but has a hard time expressing himself.
We both do.
That's what "Bros" is about.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I thought, you know what?
I like the idea of a gay man singing
a Garth Brooks inspired country song.
A love song, to the guy he's in love with.
Even though my character
doesn't love country music
but his does.
So, that's part of the gesture.
- Yeah.
- You have great taste in real life.
I'm just saying.
- [Luke] Thank you very much.
Thank you.
- I know, I noticed you liked country
so I gave you George Straight vinyl.
- Yes, back that was so-
- Just saying, dip into that.
- Absolutely, Amarillo by morning.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, it's so good.
- He's a real country fan.
- I actually tried to play
it on your record player.
Your record player
backstage was not working.
- It was not working?
- It was not working for me.
- We like to just give
you the vinyl to look at.
(background laughing)
- Oh well I took it out
because I wanted to get going and-
- We will now fix that.
- [Luke] Ah yes, heads will roll.